Narrator: It's been 10 years
since "Shark Tank"
ignited America's
entrepreneurial spirit,
and we're still
blazing a trail
for those who take their fate
into their own hands.
And tonight, branding expert
Rohan Oza returns to the Tank.
Coming on to "Shark Tank"
is not a business plan.
You need to come on
to "Shark Tank"
with a business plan.
Epstein: I know
what you're thinking.
"He looks like Kevin,
only skinnier."
‐Oh!
‐Whoa!
Killian: How much money
would it take you
to let the Shark
next to you...
[ Clippers whir ]
...give you a haircut.
‐I'm in.
‐You got to be kidding.
[ Laughs ]
You know, I made
a lot of mistakes
in this business, Kevin.
‐You don't say?
Greiner: I got good news
and bad news.
I'm gonna give you
the good news.
There's four other Sharks.
‐Oh, Lord.
♪♪
Narrator: First into the Tank
is an activity
to get to know
your friends better.
♪♪
Hey, Sharks.
My name is Dan Killian,
and I'm looking for $100,000
in exchange for a 20% stake
in my company today.
But to tell you
a little about myself,
I just turned
31 years old,
I quit a phenomenal job
after 9 years,
and I did
the one thing
that every
30‐something‐year‐old
can only dream of.
Hey, Dan!
I baked some cookies
for you and
your Shark friends.
Oh, yeah! I moved back home
with my parents, guys.
So come on in.
Great.
[ Laughter ]
Sharks, I realize this is
a funny conversation
all loving families
and friends have,
and it always involves
something that
each of you know
very, very well.
‐Money!
Killian:
That's right, parents.
Like when someone says,
"I'll give you 10 bucks if
you eat that off the ground,"
or that friend that calls
after a bad day and says,
"I swear, if someone
gave me $1,000,
I would call my boss and
I'd quit tonight, no problem."
Or you might wonder as you sit
there comfortably,
"How much money would it
take you right now
to let the Shark
next to you"...
[ Clippers whir ]
...give you a haircut.
‐[ Laughs ]
‐Now, if you're thinking about
that dollar amount,
Sharks,
you're what I call
a "Pricetitute."
[ Ding! ]
We did not
raise him that way.
[ Laughs ]
So I took these conversations
everyone's already having,
started a business,
and turned that into a game.
It's called...
[ Register dings ]
...Pricetitution.
You guessed it.
So, this game is actually
one of the best ways
to get to know more
about new and old friends.
And, no ‐‐ to answer
your first question,
you don't actually
have to do any of this stuff.
You're only guessing
how much money
it would take them
to do this.
So to better understand
one another
and help people connect
and at the end of the day,
to make my roommates
proud of me,
what's your price?
‐[ Laughs ]
‐All righty.
So, I'm gonna grab a card,
and I'm gonna take you through
kind of how to play it
and the details on it,
and then my parents, since you
are in our home right now ‐‐
we're gonna pass you out
some cookies and some milk.
[ Laughs ] You know
the way to our hearts.
‐What do we have here?
‐These are sugar cookies.
‐Oh, how cute!
‐Perfect. Thank you so much.
‐Thank you so much.
‐Are you really the parents?
‐We are.
♪♪
So, each round,
basically what happens
is someone pulls a card.
This is a giant card.
They're a little bit
smaller, obviously.
And what happens is that person
becomes the Pricetitute.
So ‐‐ So, Kevin
is the Pricetitute.
So you would read this card
aloud to everyone.
So this card says ‐‐
How much to wear wet socks
for a week straight?
O'Leary: Okay.
Killian:
So, you might not be
exactly happy
about that, right?
And what's gonna happen
is the rest of the Sharks,
the rest
of the players here,
are gonna guess your lowest
possible dollar amount
to have to do that.
Kevin's also gonna write down
his lowest possible
dollar amount
very, very honestly
to have to do this,
and whoever is closest
wins that round,
and then
they get one point.
Now, we're gonna
take a second
before we just write down
arbitrary numbers,
and we're gonna ask
a few questions.
Okay.
Kevin, what happens
when you have wet socks?
Do you absolutely hate it?
Do you just kind of hate it?
Can you deal with it?
Oh, I‐I think
it's really miserable,
and it's very bad
for fungus
and all kinds
of other issues.
So you have health concerns
beyond discomfort?
Health concerns.
Absolutely.
‐Kevin is the fungus among us.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Cuban: Okay, I'll go first.
My guess is
he will pay me $1,000.
He likes to wear
wet socks so much ‐‐
‐I think it's $1 million...
‐$1 million!
...because there's a royalty
in there somewhere.
‐I said $100,000.
‐Okay.
And I said $0, because I think
it's a great marketing ploy
for him to soak his socks
in that stupid wine he sells
and get a lot of social‐media coverage.
Are you ready for
the correct answer, please?
Yeah.
Please, Pricetitute.
‐$792,000.
‐There we go!
[ Greiner laughs ]
‐I'm closest!
‐You're the winner.
‐Winner, winner, chicken dinner.
‐I value foot health.
[ Laughter ]
Corcoran: Dan, tell us
about your background.
What were you doing
before you came up
with this stupid idea
and moved in
with your parents?
My background is
I'm a psychology major,
I have a background
in improv comedy,
and I worked
at a creative ad agency
for about nine years.
That's what I just quit
to make this.
I did a Kickstarter
on this, uh, last year,
sold a bunch over the holidays.
‐What's "a bunch"?
‐I hate "bunch."
A bunch? Uh, so with only
two months of active sales
and also focusing this entire
year on licensing offers,
which I have received
a couple ‐‐
Wait a minute, there.
Sales are
at about $40,000.
So, tell Mr. Wonderful about
the licensing opportunity.
So, the largest
toy manufacturer in the world
reached out to me,
and the largest playing card
manufacturer in the world
reached out to me.
‐What?
Where does that stand now?
So, I ended up, um,
not going forward
with both of those ‐‐
Wait a minute.
‐Whoa, whoa.
‐Danny, honey, sweetie, bootsy.
Greiner: Maybe they weren't
offering enough.
The challenge was that
they wanted to put this game
into a game subscription
mail‐order box.
Greiner: Oh.
So that's gonna be something
that's going out
every few months.
It's gonna be $50‐plus.
If you look at a game like this,
and you think about the ‐‐
the target, which is
a social, casual player,
they're not gonna be buying into
something that's 50, 60 bucks.
You were smart not to do that.
What was the other one.
Nah, that's the dumb one.
‐What's the other one?
‐So, the other one was ‐‐
Actually, I got
an above‐average advance offer.
I was actually almost gonna
go forward with it,
'cause they were gonna actually
make it their flagship game.
They said it was
the highest‐tested ‐‐
Whoa!
No wonder
you dad looks so sad.
‐Right.
‐[ Laughs ]
The reason I didn't
go through with it
was because
they insisted on having
a perpetual exclusivity
of $1,000 a year
without guaranteeing
any minimum sales.
But all you need is
a Shark that
knows royalties
to negotiate
that for you.
Do you know anyone that ‐‐
that knows that sort of thing?
Cuban: No, he doesn't.
‐That's his problem.
‐I do, actually.
What does
it cost to make,
and what are you
selling it for?
$3.09 landed, and
I'm selling it for $21.99.
‐Do we have the package?
‐Can we see the packaging?
‐Absolutely. Yeah, yeah.
‐Where is it?
‐Let's look at it.
‐Oh, yeah.
Oza:
And so you sold it...
Greiner: Oh, how cute.
two months of last year,
is that right?
Oh,
I should help them out.
Oh, oh.
You got it.
Oh, I'm sorry. I got it.
‐Here you go.
‐That's so cute.
So, obv‐obviously the shape ‐‐
the shape here
is the price‐tag shape,
so everything ties into that.
‐I like the packaging.
‐Thank you.
Greiner: It looks like
a little mailbox.
The packaging's very cool.
♪♪
"How much to wear a diaper
under my clothes tomorrow?"
‐Or here ‐‐
‐"How much to hold" ‐‐
"How much money
would it take me
to let Kevin slowly drool
into my mouth?"
[ Laughter ]
O'Leary: You know, I thought
this was poo‐poo on a stick.
I thought you were,
you know, just a bum
living at home
with your parents.
No.
Now I'm wondering,
"Is this a dumb idea or not?"
♪♪
Narrator:
All Sharks are still in.
And Kevin is wondering
about the merits
of Dan's socially interactive
game, Pricetitution.
Maybe it has some potential.
Dumb or not?
Oh, if you're asking me,
I'm gonna go with "not."
‐Yeah.
‐That's gonna be my ‐‐
That would be
a good response.
For sure, yeah.
Look, I sold
my first company
to the world's largest
toy company,
then I worked there
for two years.
I've seen how difficult
it is for people
to actually get distribution.
Very, very hard.
That's why many of them
do the license deal,
and if it has merit,
the market decides.
So I'll give you the $100,000.
I want 50%.
Oza: Oh!
‐And we're partners.
‐I appreciate that offer.
Um, it is, obviously,
higher than
what I was looking for, but ‐‐
‐It's an outstanding offer.
And I think your parents
would like it a lot.
♪♪
‐So, Dan, so...
‐Yes?
...the game this reminds me
the most of
is Cards Against
Humanity.
Mm‐hmm.
Sure.
Do you know how big
those guys have become
and what they've sold?
‐Yeah, I can ‐‐
I can tell you this.
Estimated sales for them
projected on Amazon
each month, uh,
are about, uh ‐‐
They sell 100,000 units
is what is projected on Amazon.
Wow.
I have a pretty damn
good background
in building brands.
Yep.
I think that you have
a great name here
that could be built
into a brand.
Okay.
And since Kevin is
trying to gouge you...
‐Yeah.
‐...I'll be nicer.
I would say $100,000
for 40% of the company.
Thank you for your offer.
Believe me, Mr. Wonderful's
worth the extra 10%.
I can guarantee you that.
So, you got two offers
on the table.
I don't know what
everybody else is doing?
Mom and Dad, believe it or not ‐‐
Greiner: Listen, listen!
Hear ye, hear ye!
I'll walk you into
the biggest retailers
within 24 hours.
‐Sure. Thank you.
‐The minute I saw this...
But it's not standing
around long.
...and understood it.
Yeah.
Truly, in my mind,
I was like, "Add to cart."
Like, I like it.
I'm gonna offer you
the $100,000,
also for 40%.
‐Ooh.
‐I like the game...
‐Yeah.
...but I already know that,
reading some of these,
that somebody
would do it,
and then
I would get sued.
Literally, where somebody
would read it
and then the media
would say,
"Mark Cuban encourages
someone to have a sex tape."
And so for the craziest reasons
in the world,
I'm out.
Okay. Thanks for
your time, Mark.
Corcoran: I'd like
to make an offer,
but it comes with
a contingency.
Okay.
Oza: Oh, boy.
What I don't like
about this game
is it's in a box.
The key to this game
is let your consumer
make up the questions.
Picture you getting
2,000 wild‐ass questions,
some of them obscene,
some of them ridiculous.
It's fodder
for social media.
I would like to make
an offer, again, for 50%,
'cause I think
it's gonna take a lot of work
to do what I think ‐‐
Oh, you're so greedy.
...to take it where I think
it should go,
which it should
be entirely online.
Four offers, Dan.
Mom and Dad,
can you believe it?
What are you gonna do, Dan?
‐You know what?
The power of two
is always greater
than the power
of one bald.
‐Mm‐hmm.
‐[ Laughs ]
[ Chuckles ] Lori and I feel
we could make something
out of this
pretty damn big.
We'll ‐‐
$100,000 for 40%,
but we'll come in together.
We'll split it.
But you got to make
the decision...
Would you ‐‐
...real quick.
Well, I appreciate
all the offers on the table,
first of all.
I really do.
Would, uh ‐‐ Would either
of you come down just 5%?
With how much money
you're gonna make,
you're not really gonna
care at all about that 5%.
That's the point.
Honestly, you're just
gonna be going...
That's fair.
..."cha‐ching, cha‐ching,
cha‐ching."
That's fair.
What I'm gonna do
is I'm gonna do a quick look
for the parental‐advisor
roommate check.
You have to. Mom and Dad,
give him the ‐‐
And then ‐‐ And then I'm gonna
look back at all of you.
[ Whispering indistinctly ]
♪♪
That was the nod.
That was what I was looking for.
‐All right!
‐So you two got a deal.
‐Whoo!
‐Lovely!
‐Congratulations, Dan.
‐Yay!
‐Thank you very much.
‐I love it. It's so cute!
‐Yeah. Thank you very much.
Look at the pride
at Mom and Dad's face.
‐Yeah.
‐Thank you very much.
‐Aww.
‐Congratulations, Mom and Dad.
‐Congrats, Dan.
‐Thank you so much.
Appreciate your time.
Thank you. Thank you.
Congrats, Mom.
Congrats, Dad.
Thanks for
the cookie and milk.
♪♪
"How much money
would it take me
to kiss the player
to my right
on the lips with
my eyes wide open"?
Mr. Wonderful?
I think you'd do it
for 100 bucks,
and I've got it
right on me.
[ Laughs ]
100 bucks!
No amount of money.
♪♪
Narrator: In season 9,
Air Force mechanic Tom Burden
made a deal with
Richard Branson,
Lori Greiner,
and Mark Cuban
for his non‐slip tool tray,
Grypmat.
‐Deal.
‐Wonderful.
‐Done!
‐Let's see what he's doing now.
[ Engine whirring ]
Since "Shark Tank," my business
has really taken flight.
Before "Shark Tank,"
we had $400,000 in sales.
It's now been a year
since making my deal,
and we've grossed over
$4.7 million in sales.
The benefit of having
three Sharks
is that it's opened my eyes
to expand beyond just aviation.
Working with Richard
and the Virgin companies,
we've been doing lots
of cross‐branding
with Virgin Race team
and their space programs.
Working with Mark has changed
our internal operations.
And Lori has opened the door
by introducing us to
major hardware retail outlets.
None of this would have been
possible without the Air Force.
‐Hey, guys.
‐Welcome.
Harris:
Our Air Force is seeking to tap
into more innovations
and visionary people
who can produce those
innovations like Tom.
Cuban: AFWERX is where
they take new technologies
and try to introduce them
to Air Force
and make us a little bit safer
and a lot more competitive.
It gives me great pleasure
to present
the "Inspiring Innovation Award"
to Mr. Tom Burden.
[ Applause ]
Cuban:
The Air Force has hundreds
of thousands of suppliers,
and Grypmat got chosen
out of all of them.
That's incredible.
My mission is to make
our military the most efficient
force in the world.
Cuban: What's really cool
is Tom's an airman.
When he was out there talking
in front of all these airmen,
you could just see
in their faces
how they could relate to him.
I mean, I was getting chills
listening to him.
I'm super excited for the award
and to be a part of AFWERX.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
Burden: It's only been a year
since getting my deal,
but I feel like the rest of my
life is impacted for the better.
Just a few years ago,
I was maintaining fighter jets.
Now I have a thriving company
that's being backed
by three Sharks
and has the support of
the United States Air Force.
It's a dream come true.
It's all thanks to the support
of the Air Force
and "Shark Tank."
All: Fly, fight, win!
♪♪
Narrator: Next into the Tank
is a customized filter
for every water type.
♪♪
Hi. My name's Eric Roy,
and I'm a PhD chemist
from Washington, D. C.
My company is Hydroviv,
and I'm here
seeking $400,000
in exchange
for a 10% stake.
Sharks, have you ever
traveled to a different city
and noticed that
the water tastes different
than what you're used to?
That's because the water's
chemistry is different.
Now, of course, the real issue
with drinking water
isn't taste.
It's that tens of millions
of U. S. households
have contaminants
in their water
that exceed
Public Health Goal.
This is crazy.
Now, knowing
that different cities
have different problems
with their water,
why do water‐filter companies
mass produce
one‐size‐fits‐all systems?
It doesn't take
a PhD chemist
to realize that this isn't
the best approach.
Now, at Hydroviv, we take
a completely different approach.
We build
custom water filters
that are optimized
for each customer's water.
Here's how it works.
When you place an order
for a Hydroviv system,
our "Water Nerds" dig through
water quality data
for your area,
then build a filter that's
actually matched to your water.
So if you live in an area
that's susceptible
to lead contamination,
we add more
lead‐removal media.
Or if you live in an area
that has high levels of arsenic,
we adjust
the filter's formulation
to stop the chemical
in its tracks.
So, whether you live in
Pittsburgh, Pennsylvania,
or Reno, Nevada,
we've got you covered.
Once the system's built,
we ship it to your home,
and you're able to hook it up
under your sink
to your existing faucet.
Sharks, I've seen
how poor water quality
can cripple a community,
and at Hydroviv, we can actually
do something about it.
So, who wants to be
the next Water Nerd?
‐All right.
‐Interesting.
Do we get samples?
‐First question I have, though.
There was and still is
a clear water crisis
in the state of Michigan
in many areas.
Yes, sir.
Do you have a filter
that solves for that?
So, we actually
got our start...
Oh, that's heavy.
...in response to
the Flint lead disaster.
The existing water filters
on the market
weren't designed
to handle that.
So, you know,
I was developing technology
for Department of Defense
at the time.
I set up in my studio apartment
in Washington, D. C.,
and just started building
high‐capacity
lead‐removal filters
and donating them to people
and child‐centric
organizations in Flint.
Wow.
‐Wow.
‐How much is the filter?
Average sales price
is right around $190.
It costs us $48 to make, build,
and ship it to the customer.
‐We have free shipping.
‐How long does the filter last?
Six months.
So, I want to buy
two filters, don't I?
Well, you want to buy
your up‐front system,
and then you want
to subscribe.
The cartridge itself
costs us about $10 total.
And then every six months, how
much does it cost me to buy it?
$55.25.
What does this year look like?
Let's look at the numbers.
So, we'll do
just over $325,000.
‐$325,000?
‐Yes, sir.
We're gonna
do $1.7 million next year.
Oza: Where are you
currently selling it?
Retailers? Online?
100% e‐commerce
through our website.
on your own website.
Greiner: Okay, what stood out
to me is that
you said you take out
arsenic, lead.
So let's take just
an easy, simple,
inexpensive thing
like a Brita, right?
Mm‐hmm.
You fill it up
with water.
Does that take out
any of those things?
No.
I mean, there are others
that will remove lead.
There's others that
will remove arsenic.
The problem is
when you mass produce
that single formulation,
there's only so much space
in these cartridges, right?
So if you're ‐‐ If you're trying
to do everything all at once,
you don't really
do anything very well.
Whereas what we're doing is
we're actually looking at
what that is in your water
and then blending
the filter cartridge ‐‐
How many people have,
though, lead, arsenic ‐‐
A lot.
Is there anything proprietary
about your filters?
Is it patented
in any way?
So, we have a nonprovisional
utility patent.
So, it's multiple claims.
One is the method
to rapidly,
um, assess and build
custom cartridges.
Another is the actual
construction of that cartridge.
The question for me is,
how do you plan on
creating the awareness of
the fact there's a problem?
Because at the moment,
in America at least,
I don't feel people
think there's a problem.
We're gonna
start advertising.
So, you haven't
been advertising at all?
We just ‐‐
We just started,
like, market‐research style.
Most of our inbound
traffic ‐‐
We get over 2,000 visitors
a day to our blog,
organic, and we are
converting that traffic.
Just last week, we signed on
a marketing firm
for Facebook ads.
We're starting to test those.
So, you're gonna spend
a lot of money advertising.
Yes, ma'am.
I need help ‐‐
sales and marketing.
Take the $400,000
that you're getting.
Yes, sir. Yep.
How are you deploying that
in a quick nutshell?
'Cause that will help me
understand where this ‐‐
Senior‐level
marketing person,
e‐commerce experience,
ad operations ‐‐
We need to start
to hire people like ‐‐
‐Oh, now you're losing ground.
‐Like ‐‐
Now you're
losing ground, right?
What's a senior‐level
marketing person gonna do...
Right.
...that you're not
doing already?
‐That's what I don't get.
‐Well, because right now,
we're relying on agencies.
We outsource all of
our ad operations to agencies.
A management‐level
marketing person
is just gonna want
to spend money
in new ways
to prove their value.
‐Okay.
‐Right?
‐And charge you a lot of money.
‐Where you already know ‐‐
Whereas you already know
what's working.
You just need
to scale it, right?
Right now, we don't have
anyone at our company
who wakes up thinking about
the marketing analytics,
what the data are.
How about you?
You do. You do.
That's your job.
You're the head.
Eric, what I'm struggling
with is two things.
One, I don't think
the consumers realize
that they have a need.
And then I haven't seen
a simple way
to reach an audience.
And so, I don't see
how I can help you get that.
For that reason,
I'm out.
♪♪
Greiner: For me,
how I see this,
I think the marketing's
too complicated.
While it's smart to say,
"I'm going to tailor this
towards your community,"
I think then you have
a big marketing issue of
"How do I get
that word out?"
It's a little bit
too early for me.
I'm sorry. I'm out.
Look, your product
is not a water filter.
Your product is trust.
‐Yes.
And what I've heard
is that all your customers
have come from
an authentic belief
that they believe
in your product
and you will
protect them.
I don't think
you want to go out there
and get the marketing guy
that just thinks
about every angle.
We want to get
you out there.
Right? We want to get you
scaring the hell out of people
and getting you onto shows
and just saying,
"I'm here to answer
all your questions."
This is what I used
to do with technology.
Absolutely.
I never spent
a nickel on advertising.
So, I'm interested
because I love products
that do well
by doing good.
And so I'll make you
an offer.
I'm gonna offer you
the $400,000,
but I want 20%.
Okay. Thank you
for the offer. Um...
While you're thinking
about the offer,
let me say
a couple of things.
You are the head
of the company,
and I quote you
when you said,
you "need some help
in sales and marketing."
That's the scariest words
I've ever hear
from any
of my entrepreneurs.
I write my money right off
the minute I hear that
because you are in charge
of sales and marketing.
Without that,
there's no business.
I don't think this thing
is gonna make it,
I'm sad to say,
and for that reason,
I'm out.
Okay, Eric. Now it's time
to make a decision.
Right? You know I'm not
the patient type.
O'Leary: Well,
I'll give you, Mark ‐‐
I'll give you a little
something to think about.
I don't care what he says.
Right? Eric, what do you
want to do?
‐Well, let me make it ‐‐
‐You haven't heard from Kevin.
Well, let me make it
a little clearer.
Mark may go out
by the looks of it.
There's a couple things ‐‐
I do want to speak to Barbara.
‐But I'm out.
‐No, no, no. No, I'm sorry.
‐Speak to Moneybags over here.
‐No, no. To the point of not ‐‐
Greiner: But Kevin
is still sitting here.
Cuban:
Eric, Eric. Don't talk yourself
out of an opportunity.
Eric, Kevin's gonna
make you an offer.
What do you
want to do, Eric?
Mark, you're who I came here
to get a deal with.
‐Thank you.
‐Before I accept that offer,
I do want to just
speak to the customer base.
Um, the way that ‐‐
‐Why would you mess with this?
‐Let me do it, then.
Eric, do that ‐‐
We'll discuss that
after you accept the offer.
♪♪
‐You have a deal, Mark.
‐Boom. Okay.
‐At last.
Well done, man.
I'm excited about this.
Thank you, sir.
Great job.
Thank you.
I'm excited, man.
We'll do it.
I am, too.
‐We'll make a lot of money.
‐Thank you so much.
Thanks, Eric.
Congratulations.
‐Congrats.
‐Thank you, Sharks.
‐Great job, buddy.
‐Good luck, Eric.
‐Nice job.
‐Thank you.
Just speaking
to the customer ‐‐
‐Of course!
‐You got to go.
Swivel around.
You got to go, buddy.
You got the deal.
O'Leary: Don't blow it.
Ohh, that's hilarious.
All I wanted to say to Mark
is that we're listening
to our customers.
Now that we have him
on our team,
it's ‐‐ I'm just speechless.
Greiner: Yeah, he did not like
your comment, Barbara.
[ Laughs ] He wanted
to defend himself.
Oza: But wait ‐‐
there's more!
‐He wanted to defend himself.
‐Take the offer and run.
♪♪
Since pitching Monti Kids
to the Sharks
and making a deal with Kevin,
he's introduced us to amazing
new business partners
and opportunities
and completely
fueled our growth.
Thank you, "Shark Tank,"
for the impact you've made
on entrepreneurship
and for 10 incredible years.
♪♪
Narrator: Next into the Tank
is a simple product
to get the most
out of everyday items.
♪♪
‐[ Laughs ]
‐Oh, no!
‐Oh, he's a look‐alike.
‐[ Laughs ]
There's
a good‐looking guy.
Hi, Sharks.
I'm Steve Epstein
from Tenafly, New Jersey,
and I know
what you're thinking.
"He looks like Kevin,
only skinnier."
‐Whoa!
‐[ Laughs ]
I'm here seeking $500,000
in exchange for 10%
of my company.
Sharks,
there's a big problem,
and I've literally gotten
to the bottom of it.
Every day in every country
around the world,
men and women of all ages
are wasting their time
and creating pollution
simply because they can't get to
the bottom of their bottles.
[ Bottle thuds ]
We've all been there ‐‐
the pump quits on our favorite
hair product or lotion...
[ Bottle clatters ]
...condiments, syrup,
sauce, car wax, glue,
or any other thick liquid
gets so low
that every time
we go to use it,
we have to start shaking
and pounding
to get that
last bit out.
At some point,
we just quit.
But those days are over.
I introduce to you
the Flip‐It! Cap,
an ingenious
bottle‐emptying device.
Simply attach
a Flip‐It! Cap
to any standard screw‐top bottle
and turn it upside down.
Gravity does the work
so you don't have to.
Then all you do is pull
the valve, squeeze.
So, Sharks,
who would like to join me
to take a big bite
out of waste,
improve people's lives,
and profitably do something
great for the planet?
I've got some samples
that I'd like to hand out.
‐Yeah, let's try it.
‐Bring 'em out.
Rohan, this is
our bath‐inspired package.
Oh, yeah. Thank you. I always
do need it for the bath ones.
[ Greiner laughs ]
Lori, this is our
beauty‐inspired package.
‐Thank you.
‐Is there a universal size?
'Cause all the s‐‐ The apertures
seem to be different.
Yes.
So, uh, bottle threads,
with few exceptions,
are standard
around the world.
Mini‐Me,
I have a few questions.
[ Laughter ]
All right.
Lots of
condiment manufactures,
they've already
designed the bottle
with a very large flat cap
so it can be turned over
and stored in
the fridge that way.
So, those bottles
are typically smaller
and more expensive
per ounce,
and they use
a lot more plastic
than the traditional bottle
that's filled from the top.
Greiner: Wait, wait.
What do you mean by that?
I didn't understand
your answer.
'Cause, I mean,
it's cap.
This would actually
be bigger than that.
Those flat caps that you see
on ketchup and things
by weight are tremendously
heavier than the Flip‐It! Cap,
which goes
from bottle to bottle.
You'll wash this out
and reuse it
over and over again.
Reusable, you're saying,
versus a cap.
Totally.
What is your background?
Is this all that you do?
‐Is this your everyday job?
‐No. It's not.
I run a contract
packaging company,
and that's how I know
so much about bottle threads.
You've brought this
to the market, obviously,
and what has the market said?
What are the sales like?
The market has been
very receptive.
We've done $2.5 million
in sales.
‐This year?
‐In how long a period of time?
Uh, no. In, uh,
just over four years.
‐Oh.
‐How about this year?
Okay, give me ‐‐ Could you
give me year‐by‐year, please?
The first year we started
with half a year.
It was about $177,000.
‐Okay.
The next year
it was about $650,000.
‐Okay.
‐The following year,
we went up to $740,000.
Last year, it was $655,000.
‐Oh.
‐Mini‐Me, you dropped in sales.
You went flat.
Well, I‐I was having
a little bit too much
customer concentration
at QVC.
This is a product that's
already been through
the wringer on QVC?
Oh, yeah, 65 times.
‐Oh!
‐Wow.
‐And now are you off?
‐Lori, is that good or bad?
We're not off.
We're just taking a break.
I've switched over to HSN
to expose a different,
you know, population.
Well, that's what happens when
your sales start to slow,
which is nothing
to be ashamed of.
Every product
has a cycle.
Sorry, the last year ‐‐
Does the last year ‐‐
Last year was $655,000.
This year‐to‐date,
we're at $305,000.
‐Oh.
‐Whoa.
‐How much does it cost?
‐That's a $5.99 item.
‐And what are your margins?
‐Costs me 96 cents landed ‐‐
We sell it on
our own website at $6.
‐Are you profitable, Steve?
‐I have been profitable.
I've taken money
out of the company,
but now I'm putting
money back in.
What are you gonna
use the money for?
The money is
gonna be used to build
additional,
higher‐cavitation molds
so I can place
larger orders
to bring
my price down.
Costs of goods
is not the problem.
It's revenue, declining revenue.
‐It's your revenue.
I still don't get
how you're gonna use
the $500,000
to drive revenue.
Part of it
is that last year,
we attended a conference
of merchants and distributors.
53 out of 53
in attendance
indicated that they wanted
to bring the Flip‐It! in.
So we did all
of the new vendor paperwork,
and we're waiting for the order
and waiting for the order.
‐And?
‐They don't have an answer.
They just don't have an answer.
‐That's called a "no."
‐It's like they're paralyzed.
‐Well, they want to take it.
‐But wait.
Then why don't they send you ‐‐
‐But what is ‐‐ Okay.
Everybody's too busy
trying to reinvent themselves
trying to catch
the market leader.
No! That's the world's
worst excuse ever.
You sound like Mr. Wonderful
right there, as well.
‐[ Laughs ]
‐Oh, please.
Don't sully the Wonderful
brand that way.
This happens on
"Shark Tank" so often.
Peel the onion back,
and you find out
that you have
not embraced the "no."
Steve, this thing is...
♪ Whaa‐whaa‐
whaa‐whaa‐a ♪
I'm out.
Epstein:
I'm surprised, Kevin,
because you love a product that
appeals to a broad audience.
This is men and women,
regardless of age, language,
culture, religion ‐‐
You asked for $500,000.
Right.
Your product's
in decline.
What could you possibly
use $500,000 for
that's gonna
turn it around?
‐Right. So now ‐‐
‐Steve, it doesn't add up.
‐What I need to do now, Mark ‐‐
‐I'm out.
Okay.
Why is it nobody's
biting at this product?
Everybody's trying
to play catch up to Amazon.
They've been gut punched
a couple times.
‐They don't know ‐‐
‐Worst excuse ever.
‐Well...
‐But ‐‐ But ‐‐ Hold on.
Every retailer
I deal with
has been gut punched
by Amazon...
Right.
...yet I get distribution
on my products every day.
Steve, how much
do you have in inventory?
I'm just curious.
‐At wholesale, $500,000.
‐Wow.
‐Oh!
‐$500,000 in inventory?
‐You have $500,000?
So, you have $500,000
worth of inventory.
Right.
The worst time to go
to investors for money
is when your company's
going south.
Right.
It's a disaster.
Unfortunately,
the entrepreneur
doesn't have a lot of control
of when and if he gets to appear
on "Shark Tank."
But coming on to "Shark Tank"
is not a business plan.
You need to come
on to "Shark Tank"
with a business plan.
For that reason,
I'm out.
Okay.
So, the problem for me is,
is it's almost like it just
became outmoded too fast,
because it's on
pretty much everything
in a grocery store
already.
So it's on the ketchups,
the mayos, and all of that.
And, unfortunately,
for those reasons, I'm out.
Okay.
The 53 buyers you were
hoping to call you back,
they ain't
ever gonna buy it.
But because
you had your success
by demonstrating the product
in that medium,
why would you not
make your own infomercial
or at least
a video online
that demonstrates
the product?
People are not watching
television the way they used to.
They're DVR‐ing,
they're skipping commercials.
Well, you know ‐‐ you know what?
That sounds exactly
like your other excuse
that the stores aren't
buying because of Amazon.
‐Okay.
‐But here's the problem.
You're trying to make
this thing go
when you've already lost
your interest in it.
You said it was
a side business.
I'm spending about
half my time on it.
Worse than that,
a quarter of your heart.
It's almost like you're here
announcing what used to be,
and you want us to put in
fresh money for tomorrow.
I'm out.
Look, there's always that
classic scene in a movie ‐‐
Grandma's maybe 105,
she's on the bed,
she's looking at her family,
they've all loved her...
‐[ Laughs ]
‐...they're having that moment.
They've had a great life
together, and she says,
"Pull the cord.
I'm ready."
[ Laughter ]
You got
to pull the cord.
‐Thank you all.
‐Bye‐bye.
Greiner: Good luck.
♪♪
Epstein:
We've got a lot of interest,
and this thing is gonna explode
like throwing a Ping‐Pong ball
into a room full of mousetraps.
And, um, they'll see.
I'll do it without them
just fine.
♪♪
Narrator: Next up is a healthier
version of a popular beverage.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks.
My name is Jim Otteson,
and I am
a recovering addict.
For years, I was addicted
to diet soda,
and it would be nothing
for me to drink
12 or more cans in a day.
Wow.
I knew I had
to turn my life around,
and that's why
I invented Luma.
I am from beautiful
Palo Alto, California,
and I'm here
seeking $500,000
in exchange for 20% of
my company, Luma Soda.
♪♪
Sharks, all of us like to enjoy
a refreshing beverage
once in a while, and there are
a lot of options out there,
but there's also a lot of
unhealthy stuff lurking inside.
Let's take apple juice
for example.
That's healthy, right?
Maybe not as healthy
as you might think
when you consider
that one 8‐ounce serving
of apple juice
has 6 1/2
teaspoons of sugar.
You got
to be kidding.
That is the same
as 6 1/2 sugar cubes.
Let's take another example.
Sports drinks.
The leading brands
are loaded
with 34 grams of sugar
in a serving.
That is the same
as 8 1/2 sugar cubes.
And why not just treat yourself
to a regular soda?
In one 12‐ounce can,
there are
40 grams of sugar.
That is the equivalent
of 10 sugar cubes.
That's why many people,
like myself,
turn to diet soda.
But diet sodas
have artificial sweeteners
that can be detrimental
to your health.
Luma is different.
Luma is a delicious,
all‐natural soda
with only four grams
of sugar.
Luma is sweetened with
a touch of honey and monk fruit.
Monk fruit
is a Chinese superfood
that has natural
antioxidants.
So with Luma, you get all
of that sweet, delicious flavor
of a regular soda with only
a tiny fraction of the sugar.
And it's delicious.
[ Can pops ]
Ahh!
But where are
my manners?
I have delicious samples
for all of you Sharks to try.
‐Cool.
‐Now I'm really intrigued.
We have four flavors,
and I, uh, wanted each of you
to be able
to try all four.
Oza: Oh, wow,
we have two colas ‐‐
cherry and
a regular, huh?
That's right ‐‐ Cherry Cola
and regular Cola.
‐Kevin.
‐Thank you, Jim.
O'Leary: Okay, let's all
try them together.
‐Which one first?
‐Let's go with the Cherry ‐‐
‐Should we all start Cherry?
‐Cherry Cola. Cherry Cola.
Oza: Kevin, which one
are we doing first?
‐Cherry Cola.
‐Cherry.
‐iY Chihuahua! iCaramba!
‐It's delicious.
‐Yeah.
‐It's different.
‐It tastes so sweet.
‐I don't like it.
It's kind of juicy,
but it's not juice,
and it's kind of soda‐y,
but it's not soda.
Okay, let's try
the Blood Orange.
‐That's pretty good.
‐Damn. That's good.
‐Let's try the Lime now.
‐The Lime.
‐Oh, no!
‐Odd.
Bet you don't
sell a lot of that.
O'Leary: Now, Cola's got to be
a big seller, right?
[ Burps ]
‐Don't burp!
‐It's a big seller, although,
we found that, uh, different
people have different favorites.
‐Okay, that's a little funky.
‐They're not buying the Cola.
Cola's no bueno.
Before you were
the soda king, who were you?
[ Chuckles ]
I was a trial lawyer
for 25 years.
‐Of course you were.
[ Laughs ]
‐[ Laughs ]
‐Yes.
I can tell by the pointer.
‐Why? What ‐‐ What type ‐‐
‐I love the pointer.
What type of trial law?
So, I litigated patent
infringement cases.
During that time,
I became addicted to diet soda.
I'd go through
the drive‐through,
get a Super Big Gulp
something,
first thing in the morning
every day...
I did the same thing.
...and I would fill it
two at a time
with ice all day long.
‐Wow.
‐The thing about, uh, diet soda
is the aspartame
actually makes
your blood sugar fluctuate.
Correct.
So, what are your sales
with this?
Have you been selling this?
‐Yeah.
Otteson: This year, so far
we've sold $180,000.
‐Where are you selling?
‐And where did you sell that?
We've sold directly
to consumers online.
How many
are repeat customers?
So ‐‐ So, online, uh,
our repeat customers
aren't very high.
What we get is a ‐‐
‐Not good.
Yeah.
I‐It's about 10%.
But ‐‐ But what we get
is a lot of comments
from customers saying,
"Hey, I love this.
When are you gonna
be in my area
so that I don't have
to buy it online?"
Oza: What's your price point
online?
Right now, we are selling
12‐packs online for $19.99.
Jim, how much have you
invested in this,
and have you raised
any outside money?
I haven't raised
any outside money in this,
and I have put a huge amount
of my own money.
‐How much?
‐$1.75 million.
‐[ Gasps ]
‐Oh!
‐Yow‐za!
‐Ow!
‐Wow.
Boom goes the dynamite.
That's a lot of monk fruit.
Greiner: Oh, no!
That's a lot of
monk fruit.
Oza: You ‐‐
Okay, hold on a second.
We got to back up
on this.
I'd get product development.
It's not cheap.
But you probably
make this
for a couple hundred
thousand dollars,
Then you've
been selling online...
You've been spending your money
on marketing, basically.
...with basically
15 grand a month.
I've been spending a lot
of my money on marketing.
How much do you have left
of the $1.75 million?
We don't have
very much left.
What we have is basically
$600,000 worth of inventory,
and, uh, about
$30,000 in the bank.
Why would you build up
half a million dollars
of inventory
when you're doing
$15,000 a month?
Unfortunately, I went through
a series of salespeople
who promised that we were gonna
be in retail distribution...
‐That never happens.
‐...and they failed miserably.
That's right.
They failed miserably.
So, they made you do
a big run of production ‐‐
That's right.
To get nice, pretty,
printed cans like we have,
the minimum order for a SKU
is one truckload...
Which is how many cans?
...which is 204,225 cans
per SKU.
Where did that money
come from?
That's a hell
of a lot of cash.
So, that money came
from a combination
of a home equity
line of credit.
I also borrowed against
whole life insurance.
‐Wow.
‐Oh. Oh.
‐A‐‐ But ‐‐
‐Jimmy.
It's ‐‐ It's not ‐‐ It's not
a debt on the company's ledger.
That's commitment.
You're ‐‐ You're all in.
That's debt that
I don't have to pay back.
Corcoran:
But you have all your chips
on the table here, don't you?
I have all of my chips
on the table.
Hey, Rohan, what is the path
that Jim can save Luma
from certain death?
Oza: Well, first of all,
he's got
a half a million dollars
of inventory
that he has to move
in a concentrated area
with traditional retail.
Yes.
Pick your X number
of retailers
across the state
of California,
'cause that's
where you're based,
and move
that inventory first.
So, we're in negotiations
with three large retailers,
and we expect to have
purchase orders this month.
Now I've got somebody ‐‐
I've got a sales rep
who has a personal
relationship...
You're back with the sales reps?
...with a couple
of these buy‐‐
Well [stammers] this guy
I'm not paying,
except on
a contingency.
Why didn't you do that in the
first place with all of them?
‐Well, but he didn't.
‐Well, you live and you learn.
We all go through that.
‐Live and learn.
You know, I made
a lot of mistakes
in this business, Kevin...
‐You don't say?
...and I did them
on my dime, okay?
Good for you.
I respect that
you owned up to it, Jim.
Well, the most valuable
lessons are the ones...
where you make the mistakes
and then you really learn
and you never do it again.
‐Right.
I'm the person that drinks
all the flavored waters.
I try to stay away
from the sugar, right?
I did not
like the flavors.
But I've got good news
and bad news.
I'm gonna give you
the good news.
There's four
other Sharks.
‐That's the good news?
‐[ Laughs ]
‐Oh, Lord.
‐Good Lord, Lori.
The bad news is
I'm going out.
Look, honest,
the flavor standpoint,
I thought two of them
were terrific.
The Blood Orange and
the Cherry Cola were great.
Cola is a ‐‐
It is the most difficult
category to penetrate.
It's why nobody
in flavored waters
tries to tackle cola.
If you could replicate cola
in this, I'm in.
‐Right.
‐I mean, you are dead‐on.
Reduce the sugar, give me
a healthier ingredient,
make it taste great.
Two out of the four
taste great.
Here's my problem.
To pull out
a Mr. Wonderful line,
I can pretty much
go do this myself.
Yeah, but, Rohan ‐‐
And so ‐‐
Rohan,
slow down there.
First of all, you have
a totally dedicated guy here.
Number one, you don't get
this kind of guy very often.
Secondly,
you can fix it.
Why wouldn't you
jump in here?
You know what went wrong
that he could improve it.
You like the two
out of four flavors.
Why don't you
help the guy fix it?
‐Moreover ‐‐
‐You're the only guy here
who really knows what
he's doing on this.
‐Right, so ‐‐
‐Thank you, Barbara. Moreover ‐‐
Barbara's great at that,
and I‐I respect that.
If Barbara wants to jump in,
she's all welcome.
No, no, I ‐‐
I'll tell you what,
I will give you an offer.
I'll give you half ‐‐
$250,000 ‐‐
which I was hoping
he was gonna jump in.
But only if Rohan's in.
♪♪
Narrator:
One Shark is out.
Barbara is willing
to make an offer
for Jim's low‐sugar soda
alternative Luma
if Rohan,
a beverage expert,
is willing
to partner with her.
I'll give you half ‐‐
$250,000 ‐‐
which I was hoping
he was gonna jump in.
But only
if Rohan's in.
♪♪
I know less about
the soda business than...
certainly you do,
but I know a good guy
when I see it.
He's a great guy.
He's rock solid.
‐Solid guy. I ‐‐
‐Well, and before you go out ‐‐
Hold on a second.
The problem is
there's things to fix,
but there's a concern
when you spend that much money
to generate
this little revenue.
We're effectively
a zero‐scale start‐up.
So, my point, Barbara ‐‐
and this is my world ‐‐
Your point should be
"get a really good deal."
Take advantage of it.
...is I could
create this myself.
Why would I want
to put money in
and go to a company that's
just starting from scratch?
Because you have a little bit
of a head start.
That's why, and you have
a great guy here.
Where's the head start?
I could create this,
probably, in 60 days
at a ‐‐
at a zero valuation.
Give me ‐‐
I wasn't ‐‐
What I like to do is
find smart entrepreneurs
like yourself,
'cause I'm not a smart en‐‐
‐Well, there he is.
I'm not
a smart entrepreneur,
and I like to turbocharge
what they have built.
‐And you're capable of doing it.
‐Let's do it. Let's do it.
The issue is there's nothing
to turbocharge here yet.
‐Don't do it.
‐I'm out.
[ Sighs ]
Barbara's still in.
Barbara, I mean,
I'm happy to give you advice
and coach you on this.
No, no.
I have to be honest with you.
I am not in without him. Okay?
Because I totally adore you
for being all‐in,
but I totally
mistrust your judgment...
‐Yeah, and I get that. I‐‐
‐...because of how the money
was spent and
what the net result was.
So, I'm sorry.
I'm out, too.
‐Okay.
‐[ Groans ]
You know, b‐basically what
Barbara just said to you, Jim,
is you need
adult supervision.
‐No, I didn't say that.
‐That's not what she said.
‐That's what she said.
‐No. Professional guidance.
‐I mean, look ‐‐
I have made
mistakes, and ‐‐
O'Leary: No, and ‐‐
and everybody here
appreciates the honestly
on that.
But, you know, this is
now the real world.
This is investing.
You're asking for $500,000.
That's not a small
amount of money.
I actually think you should
take the $1.7 million hit
and move on.
Every investor here
has made mistakes.
Yep.
I don't have
a perfect portfolio.
‐Nobody does.
‐Yeah.
I can't go on this journey
into oblivion.
I'm out.
I'm sorry
to hear that, Kevin.
Every entrepreneur has crises ‐‐
every single one of them.
Some own up to it,
some don't.
It's what you do now
that really is gonna
define your business.
Normally, there is
a path somewhere.
You just have to find it.
Yours is gonna be difficult,
and what I've found
in those situations
is that I go
to my biggest customer,
and I'm brutally honest,
and just lay it all on the table
like you did for us,
and try to find a way
to work with them and say,
"Look, I've got
all this inventory.
Work with me."
And really discount it to cost
if you have
to to move out
of your inventory.
Learn your lessons,
use whatever cash that
you create from that,
and then start moving forward
as a smarter person
and smarter about
your industry.
But?
It's ‐‐ It's not
a fit for me,
so for those reasons,
I'm out.
‐All right.
‐Wish you the best.
‐Thank you very much.
‐Yes. Good luck.
‐Thanks for your time.
‐Thank you.
♪♪
Otteson: Getting an investment
from a Shark
would have made all
the difference in the world
for our company,
so it's gonna be
an uphill battle,
but we're gonna ‐‐
we're gonna keep fighting.
♪♪